[Musica]
Oggi siamo qui per parlare del tempo del
tempo che dedichiamo alle relazioni e ai
social network cerchiamo di rispondere
seriamente a questa domanda quanto tempo
dedichiamo davvero ai Social al
giorno
tutto comincia con la rivoluzione
industriale che ha modificato la
velocità con la quale comunichiamo se in
passato per inviare una lettera scritta
a mano tramite posta Oppure ad una
cartolina dalle vacanze di montagna
all'amico lo fate ancora la
comunicazione era lenta ci volevano
giorni settimane mesi necessari per
l'invio e la ricezione del messaggio
Oggi invece per inviare un messaggio Ci
vogliono qualche minuto qualche secondo
questo Grazie all'applicazione di
messaggistica ai Social e ad internet la
comunicazione è diventata veloce
istantanea frenetica stressante
soprattutto dal punto di vista emotivo
vi siete mai arrabbiati perché il vostro
amico non risponde subito ad un
messaggio su WhatsApp e voi avete visto
la doppia spunta
Ecco oltre ad aver la velocità con la
quale comunichiamo ha modificato anche i
nostri bisogni identificati inizialmente
da Abraham Maslow nella sua piramide del
consumatore Maslow identifica cinque
bisogni fondamentali dell'essere umano
partendo dal bisogno fisiologico quindi
del mangiare del bere del dormire segu
il bisogno di sicurezza e quindi di
sentirsi protetti poi il bisogno di
amore di affetto di stima per per
arrivare
[Musica]
all'autocertificazione
prendendo in considerazione solo le basi
delle due piramide il bisogno di
connessione viene equiparato al bisogno
fisiologico del mangiare del bere del
dormire anche per voi la connessione è
diventata un bisogno fondamentale così
come il mangiare il bere e il
dormire secondo lo studio di we are
Social relativo al 2022 gli italiani
spendono in media un or e 50 minuti
circa al giorno sui
social questo per un totale di 6 ore
circa al giorno onine Quindi in un mese
sono più di 50 ore dedicate ai social
network e più di 190 ore dedicate onine
190 ore sono più di una settimana più di
7 8 9 giorni consecutivi senza mai
staccare 24 ore al
giorno anche se questi dati sono
diminuiti rispetto al
2021 quello che davvero mi preoccupa è
che un italiano su due dichiara di
utilizzare social network solamente per
impiegare per sprecare il tempo
libero vi capita mai di perdervi e di
rendervi Conto di passare davvero troppo
tempo
on più tempo del
previsto questo perché viviamo in una
società connessa dove abbiamo sviluppato
una sorta di dipendenza dalla tecnologia
E dai social network la dipendenza da
internet nasce con Ivan Goldberg nel 95
è lui ad introdurre l'idea che sia
possibile sviluppare una dipendenza da
internet così come dalla droga e
dall'alcol quali sono Allora le fasi
della dipendenza da
internet Beh tutto comincia con un
iniziale coinvolgimento una curiosità un
desiderio di scoprire questo mondo nuovo
che ben presto sostituisce la vita reale
perché le attività Le esperienze le
relazioni sembrano essere molto più
appaganti molto più interessanti nel
mondo virtuale ed ecco che ci troviamo
già nella terza fase la fuga Quindi
cerchiamo rifugio nel mondo virtuale
perché la realtà non ci piace
più alcuni esempi della nuova dipendenza
da internet Sono la dipendenza da online
shopping dalle applicazioni di Dating
dalle relazioni virtuali e anche dai
videogiochi come se non bastasse siamo
alle porte di una nuova dipendenza la
dipendenza dall'intelligenza artificiale
che sta sviluppando preoccupazione
soprattutto a livello di automazione di
privacy di impatto sull'occupazione Ma
anche sulla creatività
umana E allora perché semplicemente non
riusciamo a smettere Beh perché la
dipendenza crea questo bisogno
irrefrenabile di utilizzare la la
tecnologia e i social network come se
non bastasse ci sono queste tendenze
sociali come ad esempio la Fear of
missing out la fomo la paura di perdere
qualcosa che gli altri stanno Vivendo e
condividendo onl in quel momento il
vostro amico che si trova in ferie alle
vacanze ha andato a una festa e ha
appena pubblicato una Story noi vogliamo
assolutamente vederla perché tra 24 ore
non sarà più possibile e non voglio
perdermela
assolutamente oppure ci sono le
Challenge popolari soprattutto tra gli
adolescenti e sui social network che
spingono alla costante ricerca di
approvazione sociale e di emulazione
degli altri partono con una semplice
banale sfida come quella di buttarsi un
secchio di acqua ghiacciata addosso però
arrivano anche ai selfie pericolosi ai
video
pericolosi Insomma l'abuso di internet
può avere conseguenze molto
significative sulla salute dell'essere
umano in alcuni casi può portare persino
alla
morte allora come facciamo a superare
questa dipendenza da internet dalla
tecnologia E dai Social e a
riequilibrare la nostra vita
Beh ci sono alcune azioni concrete che
possiamo attuare inizialmente
identifichiamo degli spazi Tech free
degli spazi Technology free in cui
durante determinate attività oppure
orari ci impegniamo a non utilizzare la
la tecnologia Quindi durante l'orario di
pranzo durante una passeggiata all'aria
aperta non tocchiamo il telefono non
navighiamo sui social oppure cerchiamoci
nuovi Hobby nuove attività usciamo di
casa troviamo nuovi modi di socializzare
che non siano connessi al telefono ad
internet alle App azioni di
messaggistica Oppure ai social
network e
poi last but not
least cerchiamo iniziamo di a monitorare
il tempo che dedichiamo al telefono ogni
giorno facciamolo insieme tutti
adesso prendete dalla vostra tasca il
cellulare tutti
quanti Internet è acceso sicuramente
bene andate su Play Store oppure su App
Store e scrivete screen
Time scaricate Una delle
applicazioni che vi escono dalla lista
delle proposte e adesso ogni sera andate
a vedere quanto tempo dedicate davvero
al telefono ai social network e
pensateci bene che cosa avrei potuto
fare in tutto quel tempo durante la
giornata è vero che non ho tempo per i
miei amici per le relazioni per il mio
fidanzato per la famiglia cosa avrei
potuto fare in tutto questo tempo
e ora che diamo importanza alle
relazioni alle persone che davvero ci
stanno vicine nella vita reale E che
cerchiamo di riequilibrare e di non
perderci in questo mondo virtuale che
tanto ci
isola prendiamo in mano il nostro tempo
e la nostra
vita